let's go to the next story here uh you
guys saw what mr beast did i don't know
if you saw that on a youtube star mr
beast created a real life squid game set
and had people compete for 456 000
which is ridiculous if you haven't seen
this video within four days the video
got a hundred million views in four days
now here's a budget that they had can we
play any of it no no we cannot no we
cannot youtube star mr b shared his
recreation of squid game which included
full-scale sets you can put up the
images so people can see it costumes
that look just like the ones in the show
and a total cost you ready three and a
half million dollars to create the exact
set oh yeah this is a squid game netflix
most watched show of all time is a
korean drama series about a group of
morally grey characters who took part in
children's games and deadly twists in
order to win enough money to pay their
debts everyone in this video game wore
costumes inspired by the show including
mr beast who was wearing the game
masters black clothing mr b said three
and a half million dollars was spent on
a real life squid game which was partly
sponsored by video game brawl stars he
said on that he spent around two million
dollars to build and produce a one and a
half million dollar prizes for the
recreation fyi you saw the tweet uh uh
kai sent us to us yesterday he said
squid game got some 85 million viewers
that watch it on netflix or whatever it
is he said
mr b's got 20 million more viewers than
the show did it's trending towards
working intense craziness when you think
about that what are your thoughts on
that
i think mr beast is he knows his
audience probably better than almost
anybody in the space he's incredible at
understanding his audience and he has a
great team around him that's able to you
know capitalize on the moment you would
think like you know squid game when you
do these kind of meme things you got to
be like right off the way we were like
because squid game was a story weeks ago
but for him to do it it was also the way
that they pulled it off if you watched
it was incredible man i mean like did
you watch his video yeah it was
incredible i haven't seen him also i'm
gonna state for the record squid game
remarkably overrated
communist propaganda anybody old enough
to have ever seen uh you know running
man understands the concept i mean this
was but but that's neither here today mr
beast you are indeed a beast incredible
now my big question becomes from uh from
a philosophical standpoint i don't i i i
i can see i can say we're going off the
air safer off the air but why how much
money do you think he made off of that
150 million viewers and is it better to
have a subscription model with paying
viewers as opposed to an ad revenue
here's that's a great question and we
can kind of transition that into mafia
states of america this is what most
people don't understand when it comes
down to youtube and adsense right so
what he produces is a hundred percent
qualified for adsense which means what
per million views he'll make you know
eight to twelve thousand dollars because
probably a lot less to be honest with
you because the heavy heavy demographic
the demographics of his worldwide
audience the cpm's are gonna be way less
well but in us let's just see so let's
just say seven thousand dollars put it
at seven thousand per million views yeah
seven thousand dollars per million views
here's the thing
people think by the way say say we do
mafia states of america what do you
think the adsense is on that
what do you think the adsense is on that
nothing do you know why
who the hell wants to advertise a coffee
company on a mafia uh you know killing
each other i killed 19 people yeah you
know what pfizer is going to endorse
their vaccine on our video you know oh
ford is going to come and advertise that
is the part where people don't realize
how adsense works he's got an adsense
machine going on right now he's crushing
it doing a great job adding more power
to him love seeing what is taking place
i spoke at a school
two weeks ago or whatever was veterans
day i don't know what veterans day was a
couple weeks ago i can't tell you how
many kids today who are eight nine 10 11
12 years old say what do you want to be
when you grow up i want to be a
youtuber so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]